c'est le sien ch notre invité politique
ce matin c'est Eric cocrel le député
insoumis de scène Saint-Denis bonjour
bonjour vous êtes président de la
commission des finances de l'Assemblée
nationale alors nous sommes ensemble
pendant une vingtaine de minutes pour un
entretien en partenariat avec la presse
régionale qui est représenté aujourd'hui
par Fabrice Vess Redon bonjour Fabrice
vous êtes je le rappelle vous êtes je le
rappelle rédacteur en chef au groupe
etbra des journaux de l'Est de la France
Éric cocrel on va commencer par parler
de la hausse du prix de l'électricité
qui a été confirmé hier soir par le
ministre de l'Économie Bruno Le Maire
une hausse du prix à partir du mois de
février entre 8,6 % et 9,8 % ça
correspond et bien au rétablissement
d'une taxe du gouvernement à la fin du
bouclier énergétique Bruno Leem l'a
justifié c'est la fin du quoi qu'il en
coûte il faut remettre d' plom nos
finances publiques ça peut paraître
cohérent alors c'est c'est pas pas
tellement la seulement la fin du
bouclier énergétique parce que pour bien
comprendre ça ne correspond pas à une
augmentation du prix de gros de
l'électricité qui a baissé
considérablement c'est une taxe que
remet le gouvernement d'ailleurs que
qu'ugment le gouvernement bon moi je
suis un peu étonné parce que déjà prime
à bord le gouvernement nous dit les
classes moyennes les classes
intermédiaires il y a un problème on
reconnaît le problème de pouvoir d'achat
donc il faut baisser les impôts de 2
milliards on y reviendra peut-être tout
à l'heure et puis la première mesure
qu'il fait c'est d'augmenter le prix de
l'électricité au-delà j'allais dire de
l'augmentation des revenus des Français
donc très clairement vous en prenez au
pouvoir d'achat sur un bien qui pour moi
a besoin qui est pour moi fondamental et
en plus sans discernement l'augmentation
bon elle va être modulée si j'ai bien
compris enfin globalement elle est quand
même à peu près la même pour pour tout
le monde donc je trouve que c'est une
mesure qui moi m'étonne surtout dans un
moment où on le voit bien là on vient de
vivre des des des moments très froids il
y a des gens y compris qui meurent de
qui meurent dans la rue faut le redire
parce qu'ils sont sans abri et on
augmente le prix de l'énergie moi je je
comprends pas très bien cette logique je
vous rappelle que le pouvoir d'achat des
Français c'est la consommation populaire
et que la consommation populaire c'est
ce qui a permis en 2023 justement qu'on
ne rentre pas en récession contrairement
quasiment à l'Allemagne donc c'est pas
je pense qu'économiquement ça ne se
tient pas donc selon vous il fallait
encore continuer ce quoi qu'il en coûte
pour amortir le prix de l'énergie qui tu
as creusé les déficit là la différence
c'est que l'État va prendre une taxe
c'est pas c'est pas le fait que ça lui
coûte c'est pas le prix gros de
l'électricité encore une fois qui
augmente donc je pense qu'il fallait
je pense qu' fallait continuer à amortir
cette question ou alors on n pas de
discours sur le pouvoir d'achat des des
Français c'est un peu tout ça est un peu
contradictoire justement sur le prix de
l'électricité le marché de l'électricité
on avait senti la semaine dernière un
Emmanuel Macron plutôt optimiste en
disant que les Français allaient
bénéficier finalement du coût inférieur
de l'électricité nucléaire qui est
produite par la France est-ce que vous
aussi vous êtes optimiste sur l'avenir
du prix de l'électricité je suis pas
optimiste d'abord parce que on a
dérégulé le marchéélectricité on l'a
laissé au March justement au marché au
privés en plus il est basé en Europe ça
continue malgré les critiques de la
France sur la question du gaz donc tout
est fait pour que au moindre alléa
l'électri remonte et je ne crois pas du
tout contrairement au gouvernement que
l'avenir à la fois pour des questions
environnementales mais des questions
synergie soit justement le nucléaire
donc je pense que on peut avoir à
nouveau des sous-bressaux d'ailleurs la
plupart des économistes sont très
prudents là-dessus au niveau du
prixélectric et donc c'était vraiment
pas le moment de remettre 10% un peu
moins de 10 % parce qu'ils ont essayé de
tenir leur promesses de d'augmentation
du prix comment les moi la question
concrète c'est comment des gens qui
aujourd'hui n'y arrivent pas ont subi
des augmentations du panier alimentaire
d'après vos confrères du Parisien de 20
% en 24 mois comment ils vont faire pour
aussi palier à cette augmentation en
tout cas tous les Fran pour tous les
Français ça va pas être évident
peut-être une minorité mais pour
beaucoup de Français ça va être vraiment
compliqué alors et cqur le weekend a été
marqué par des manifestations
d'agriculteur la colère du monde
agricole continue de monter en France et
même partout en Europe le motif de la
cons de la contestation et notamment et
bien la lourdeur des normes
environnementales qui complexifi
l'activité des exploitations agricole
que faire pour répondre à cette colère
est-ce qu'il faut reculer revenir sur
certaines normes écologiques ça j'ai
bien compris que c'est ce que le
gouvernement veut laisser entendre que
la la revendication principale serait
liée à des normes environnementales et
donc j'ai entendu hier madame berger de
la démagogie en tapant à la fois sur ce
qui se passe au niveau européen moi je
ne suis pas je n'ai pas votre
appréciation c'est très diverse son les
régions Mo je crois d'abord que la
principale revendication des des
agriculteurs et je les comprends si on
veut vivre notre travail voilà ils ont
eu les prix agricoles ont baissé 10 % en
un an et en même temps les prix de
l'alimentaire notamment avec
l'agroobusiness industriel ont augmenté
je l'ai dit alors de 20 % en 24 mois bon
bah il y a un gaps les gens se demandent
comment ça se fait que certains euh
augmentent leur marge parce que c'est ça
produisent en plus de l'inflation et
puis nous on arrive même pas à venir de
prix agricoes donc il faut d'abord faire
faire face à ça moi je pense que c'est
ça le je regardais par exemple dans dans
l'ouest de la France les agriculteurs
d'abord ils vont devant l'actalis qui
est un producteur pour pour contester
justement enfin le ceux qui produisent
du lait pour contester ces questions
donc nous on avait proposé des prix
planchés des prix rémunérateurs lors
d'une proposition de loi je parle du
groupe franceç insoumise et qui avait
d'ailleurs cet aspect de la proposition
avait été majoritaire
notre niche je pense que c'est ça qu'il
faut faire très rapidement les
agriculteurs doivent pouvoir vivre de
leur travail voilà à mon avis ce qui
déjà est essentiel alors l'un des motifs
quand même de la colère c'est la fin
d'une exonération fiscale sur le gazol
non routier est-ce qu'il faut et bien
rétablir cette exonération fiscale pour
satisfaire les agriculteurs moi je on
peut pas on peut pas dissocier le besoin
de la
lutte sur les questions
environnementales de la question de
l'agriculture voilà y compris d'ailleurs
pour les agriculteurs eux-mêmes donc
autant on peut imaginer je crois par
exemple des aides qui permettent aux
agriculteur de faire face à cette
augmentation autant par exemple la lutte
contre la décarbonation me semble aussi
vitale aussi fondamentale pour tout le
monde y compris les agriculteurs parce
qu'il respirent le même le même air que
moi ils sont pe levés j'allais dire en
premier lieu par exemple par les mêmes
les mêmes
produits type glyphosate et aut donc moi
je je suis pas certain que ça soit la la
question de l'exonération qui est à posé
par contre la question d'aide pour les
les les aider nous nous on avait proposé
par exemple que sur euh on avait fait
une proposition loi là aussi qui euh qui
est d'ailleurs passé à l'Assemblée on
attend qu'elle passe au Sénat pour venir
à l'Assemblée euh sur par exemple des
prix de l'EDF qui soi tarifé pour les
agriculteurs pour les commerçants et
cetera qui soit euh euh qui qui
permettent justement de de de d'éviter
des souousbressau je pense que cette
voie elle là mais encore une fois euh
vous savez les agriculteurs si ils ont
ils sont mieux rémunérés s'ils gagnent
mieux leur vie si aussi on le on leur
assure une protection contre une
concurrence internationale avec les
accords de libre échange peut-être accep
considérontils que l'augmentation sur le
gasoil est plus supportable à partir
momentù il gagne m leur vie donc le
problème principal il est là d'abord
Fabrice une dernière question politique
sur cette colère du monde agricole oui
on parle de travailleurs pauvres pour
beaucoup pour beaucoup et la droite qui
suicide d'ailleurs beaucoup qui suicide
absolument la droite et l'extrême droite
conserve la faveur des agriculteurs
comment vous l'expliquez est-ce que
est-ce que fill la nu pourrait un peu
oublier les paysans non non on n pas
oublié les paysans mais non non on a des
liens d'ailleurs avec des nombreux
syndicats agricoles moi cette semaine
prés de la commission des finances c'est
un hasard c'était pas prévu mais je
rencontre monsieur Rousseau donc je
crois pas qu'on soit du tout éloigné en
tout cas on n'est pas éloigné des
préoccupations du monde agricole mais
comme sur les médias on narrête pas de
répéter que monsieur bardellaa a des
succès que c'est la PR la le préambule
des des européennes bah à la fin ça
devient autoréalisateur quoi moi je moi
je veux pas regarder ça très franchement
c'est pas mon sujet aujourd'hui mon
sujet aujourd'hui c'est que une très
très grande partie une très grande
majorité du monde agricole des éleveurs
n'y arent pas d'accord subit des
conditions de vie qui sont souvent
insupportables beaucoup de célibataires
beaucoup de personnes qui qui sont dans
des dans des y compris dans des dans des
environnements sociaux très compliqués
et moi je pense que c'est ça qu'il faut
résoudre après on verra bien pour qui
vote à qui ça ça ça ça fonctionne ce que
j'observe simplement c'est que euh la
force qui aujourd'hui s'oppose à la fois
propose ses prix planchés s'oppose au
libreéchant et propose justement des
solutions de souveraineté alimentaire
produit dans des conditions
environnementales qui je dire
satisfassent d'abord les agriculteurs
c'est la France insoumise c'est pas le
rassembl national é ocrel on va parler
de la loi immigration puisqu'il y avait
des dizaines de milliers de manifestants
partout en France hier pour défiler
contre ce texte qui a été voté par le
Parlement en décembre dernier est-ce que
vous pensez que vraiment que vraiment
ces manifestations puissent faire
changer d'avis manuel Macron sur la la
promulgation de cette loi je l'espère
manifestement d'après ce que j'ai
compris Emmanuel Macron et Madame madame
borne avant de de de d'être démissionné
euh trouve que leur loi elle-même est
trop dur puisqu'ils compte sur le
Conseil constitutionnel pour l'abger ce
qui est quand même un peu bizarre he bon
c'est une loi qui puise dans le
programme de l'extrême droite très
clairement euh donc il enfin qui pour
moi est antirépublicaine je le dis je le
dis tranquillement c'est qui instaure la
préférence nationale qui remet en
question le droit du sol qui instaure
une déchéance de nationalité selon votre
origine toute chose qui est contraire à
nos principes républicains donc j'espère
bien que le gouvernement refusera de
promulguer une loi qui en plus ne règle
rien le problème de notre pays c'est
l'accueil deimmigration c'est ça qui
crée de la marginalité c'est ça qui crée
des problèmes on est plus contrairement
à ce qu'on dit si on regarde les
chiffres réellement on est plus en ce
moment un grand pays d'immigration rien
que par exemple l'immigration de travail
c'est 16 % seulement de l'immigration
qui explique d'ailleurs pourquoi il y a
autant de travers en papier parce que
notre économie en réalité a besoin de de
de mimigré comme l' eu souvent besoin en
l'histoire donc tout ça est une à la
fois indigne injuste inefficace et en
plus vous le dit dit à des rollands
d'extrême droite qui m'inquiète donc
j'espère bien que ça va peut être
promulgué et sinon j'espère bien même si
monsieur fabus a eu raison de réagir en
disant qu'il fallait pas
instrumentaliser politiquement le
Conseil constitutionnel mais j'espère
bien que une très grande partie de cette
loi sera balayée par le Conseil
constitutionnel vous pensez qu'il faudra
manifester au-delà vous faisiez partie
des manifestants ce weekend euh
exceptionnellement je ne manifeste pas
c'était rare parce que j'avais d'autres
problèmes dont on parlera après sur ma
circonscr les semaines précédentes ouais
voilà bien sûr le 14 j'étais en train de
manifester vous vous pensez qu'il faudra
manifester au-delà de la oui oui je
pense décision du Conseil constitionnel
oui j'ai cru comprendre qu'il y avait
déjà un rendez-vous prévu début février
bien sûr faut continuer à se mobiliser
euh tout simplement parce queon peut pas
admettre de donner on peut pas admettre
de de mettre dans une situation très
compliquée des centaines de milliers de
personnes qui vivent sur notre
territoire qui souvent l'enrichissent
par leur travail par leurs enfants qui
vont à l'école voilà il faut arrêter de
de vouloir diviser les Français de de
courir derrière leur rassemblé nationale
qui utiliseent l'immigration en gros
pour pour faire en sorte que on
s'interroge pas sur un système injuste
mais que les gens considèrent que leur
problème c'est le travailleur à côté
parce qu'il a pas la même C de peau que
c'est un vieux truc et je veux dire
là-dessus bah il faut il faut argumenter
se battre mobiliser donc la bataille va
continuer sur l'immigration notamment
avec la réforme de l'aide médical d'État
qui est promise par Gabriel
malheureusement oui parce que j'ai
l'impression que ce gouvernement va
continuer à puiser du côté de l'extrême
droite son programme éc cocrel quelques
questions sur l'affaire qui touche
l'école Stanislas école privée
catholique à Paris il est actuellement
une quê de police en cours pour
homophobie et sexisme concernant un
intervenant de l'école privée Stanislas
cela fait suite et bien au rapport très
critique de l'inspection de l'éducation
nationale sur cet établissement est-ce
qu'il faut suspendre tout simplement le
contrat d'association de cet
établissement avec l'tat écoutez il y a
pas très longtemps dans le nord de la
France on a eu des mesures assez
drastiques vis-à-vis d'une école euh qui
était une école euh
euh sur enfin qui qui était Islam sur
l'islam pardon euh je pense qu'il faut
faut pas faire de point de mesure donc
parce que je crois je crois que le
rapport ne pointe pas seulement la
responsabilité d'une personne si j'ai
bien compris lieu rapidement il y a
d'autres faits qui sont qui sont donc
bon il faut il faut il y a une enquête
tant mieux et je trouve que la mairie de
Paris a eu raison de de cesser d'aider
ces écoles mais ça nous permet déjà de
pointer quand même un souci global qui
est il y a un rapport de la Cour des
comptes cétait qui est sorti en juin il
y a une mission d'information avec mon
collègue notamment Paul vanner à
l'assemblée qui travaille là-dessus
c'est qu'on s'aperçoit que d'abord un
les écoles privées sous contrat servent
surtout du séparatisme social confè les
choix madame ou et qui sont très claires
deux qu' y a pas d'égalité parce que ces
écoles contrairement à ce qu'on dit un
ne sont pas gratuites deux sont aidés à
75 % par les donniers publics plus les
aides des collectivités et choisissent
leurs élèves et donc il y a il y a il y
a il y a vraiment un problème majeur qui
se pose donc moi je je pense qu'il faut
pas la question n'est pas d'ouvrir la
guerre scolaire mais la question c'est
un peu d'équilibrer les choses voilà on
peut pas sans arrêt nourrir des écoles
qui pas toutes hein donc c'est revoir
les financements c'est revoir les
financements publics c'est ce que vous
dites ah bah en tout cas si il y a un
problème parce que s'il y a un
financement public mais d'un autre côté
d'après un rapport de la Cour des
comptes il y a aussi peu de contrôle sur
les gestions sur ce que ce qu'on
enseigne éventuellement pour certaines
écoles pas toutes Je je veux pas
schématiser vous admirerez avec moi que
c'est pas normal l'école publique est
beaucoup plus contrôlée vous parlez de
la ministre de l'Éducation nationale
Amélie ou à casterra qui finalement a
mis la lumière sur l'école Stanislas euh
la semaine dernière et d'ailleurs ce
weekend on a appris euh que euh son fils
avait bénéficié d'un système de
contournement des règles de parcours sup
comme d'autres élèves de l'école
Stanislas un système de contournement
pour permettre au lycéens de Stanislas
d'être accepté dans la classe
préparatoire de l'école Stanislas avec
euh finalement cette nouvelle révélation
est-ce que la ministre peut encore
rester à son poste je crois pas je crois
pas je d'ailleurs je je me demand à quel
niveau euh enfin tout tout ça est un peu
lunaire quand même c'est si on veut
affaiblir la préparation des Jeux
Olympiques on fait ce qu'on a fait parce
que globalement madame Meral faisait le
job voilà moi je l'ai côtoyé à plusieurs
reprises dans ma circonscription qui est
au cœur des Jeux Olympiques elle faisait
le job et là j'allais dire que la
ministre de l'Éducation est en train de
fragiliser la ministre des Sports donc
je je pense qu'on ferait bien de de de
de de lui enlever cette attribution
parce qu'en plus de ça très franchement
aujourd'hui elle est discrédité
vis-à-visenseignant vous lui conservez
sa fonction Mo décider mais l'urence moi
je la remet pas en question sur le
ministère des sports on peut être pour
ou contre les Olympiques mais question
compliqué quand même compliqué comment
c'est compliqué qu'est-ce de priver
quelqu'un d'une partie de ses
prérogatives après l'avoir nommé non
vous sa vous il va y avoir des nouvelles
décisions au niveau du gouvernement moi
je pense qu'il vaut mieux se rendre
compte avant d'une erreur et de du fait
que tout ça est un point compliqué en
plus très franchement dès le départ je
vois pas très bien comment vous êtes à
la fois ministre des Sports le des Jeux
Olympiques et ministre d'éducation
nationale qui si j'ai bien compris est
une des priorités annoncé par Monsieur
hatal et Monsieur Macron donc tout ça me
semble une erreur qui serait temps de
rectifier mais qui changera pas par
ailleurs la politique à l'école la
politique à l'école c'est qu'il faut
plus de moyens pour baisser le nombre
d'élèves par classe plus d'enseignant
mieux rémunérés sans qu'ils aient besoin
de travailler plus et ça c'est pas de
toute façon madame OUAC et cetera qui
est responsable de cette politique avec
Ocal on va évoquer un sujet qui concerne
votre circonscription la scène
Saint-Denis puisque la semaine dernière
deux jeunes de Saint-Denis ont été tués
violemment de coup de couteau Fari 17
ans est mort samedi après avoir été
agressé devant son lycée et ça c'était
après la mort de ce 14 ans qui a été
poignardé dans une station de métro de
la ville de Saint-Denis ça c'était
mercredi comment on explique selon vous
ce déchaînement de
violence déjà on comment dire on essaie
d'apporter du du du réconfort aux
parents parce que c'est absolument
dramatique dans les deux cas moi hier
j'étais apporté mes condoléances à la
famille de faride de un un enfant de 17
ans parfaitement intégré apprécié par
tous ces éducateurs qui faisaient du
foot et cetera et qui meurt à la sortie
de son lycée enfin je sais pas si vous
si je pense que vous rendez compte de ce
que ça donne mais ceans 14 ans bon déjà
c'est la première chose à faire ensuite
comment on l'explique euh on l'explique
très certainement parce que à un moment
donné il se trouve que j'ai j'ai j'ai
fait un colloque compris l'Assemblée sur
cette question on sait qu'il y a des des
violences interquartiers qui existent de
Rix alors c'est pas nouveau
contrairement ce qu'on dit arrêtons de
il y a toujours eu des violence comme ça
en sauf que manifestement c'est avec des
armes plus dangereuses plus jeunes les
réseaux sociaux enflamment facilement
les choses et puis donne des points de
rendez-vous faciles et donc tout ça peut
vite beaucoup plus vite dégénérer donc
moi je pense qu'à court terme là il faut
déjà trouver les les les coupables euh
que la justice passe à moyen terme et
c'est ce qui est en train d'être fait en
Sani il faut que les parents parlent
entre eux il y a des associations qui
travaillent à ça pour que les parents
des différents quartiers se parlent pour
que les les les les jeunes à nouveau se
rediscutent qu'on essaie de trouver des
médiations et puis à long terme bah il
faut peut-être mettre le paquet à
nouveau
sur les centres culturels les éducateurs
l'école je l'ai dit tout à l'heure moi
je suis très jeis très pourquoi
là-dessus on a régressé en Saint- bah en
tout cas on n pas on n pas ça a pas
progressé et puis je vous fais remarquer
qu'il y a un nouveau rapport il y avait
eu le rapport Cornu gentil sur la scè s
que député républicain qui expliquait
que la sè s contrairement à ce qu'on
peut dire on a toujours l'impression que
il y a plein d'argent qui est envoyé sur
les les les les les villes populaires ce
qui est pas vrai la S Sani était défic
dans tous les services publics par par
rapport à la moyenne nationale avec
pourtant une population très jeune et et
pauvre bon et ça ça s'est pas amélioré
d'après un nouveau rapport Stéphan peu
mon collègue député de saint-nis donc à
partir de là il faut remettre le paquet
un service public dans les écoles avec
des des ilut il faut trouver ce moyen je
l'ai dit des travailleurs sociaux je
l'ai dit aussi on parle peu mais il faut
le préciser la question de la santé
mentale dans ce pays il manque des psis
dans toutes les écoles il faut essayer
de prévenir à l'avanceé il y il y a un
problème quand comprenez bien que quand
un enfant de 19 ans un jeune de 17 ans
poignarde un autre enfant c'est qu' a il
y a quelque chose qu'il faut prévenir
donc il faut mettre le paquet là-dessus
moi je sais je suis comme Hugo une école
vaut mieux qu'une prison en général donc
c'est là-dessus qu'il faut appuyer et
puis là pour l'instant à court terme bah
il faut effectivement mais bon c'était
mercredi les deux événements étaient
mercredi depuis notamment grâce à grâce
au aux décisions de la mairie de la
police et autres il y a pas eu d'autres
événements aussi dramatique donc et
c'est pas non plus le quotidien de la SC
sa je VO à le dire quand même aussi
arrêtons les amalgames okrel en tant que
président de la commission des finances
de l'Assemblée nationale vous avez
demandé des documents au ministère de
l'Économie concernant une affaire qui
touche fiscalité et football une affaire
de faveur fiscale qui aurait pu être
accordée en 2017 par le ministère des
comptes publques au PSG pour finaliser
le transfert de Neymar ministère des
comptes publiques dirigé alors par un
certain Gérald de d'mananan est-ce que
vous avez une réponse de ber pas encore
mais c'est normal je l' demandé mercred
mardi mercredi dernier donc c'est normal
que je l'ai pas encore aussi vite mais
j'ai demandé de l'avoir vite chacun
comprendra donc c'est vrai que si cette
semaine j'ai pas de nouvelles j'iris
peut-être à Bery ce que j'ai le droit de
faire euh pourquoi parce qu'il faut voir
deux choses est-ce qu'il y a une
anormalité dans les rcrits qui auraiit
été d'après vos confrères des différents
confrères notamment Médiapart qui aurait
été euh euh permis alors faut vérifier
si c'est monsieur d'manin qui les a
permis donc faut que je je vois ça donc
on pourrait tomber dans l'illégalité bah
je sais pas je vais voir en tout cas il
faut voir si euh il y a eu quelques
chose qui n'est pas dans dans les normes
c'est-à-dire que bon il arrive qu'il a
des réscrits des rcrits c'est des
quelque part des accords fiscaux qui
sont faits par par la par le la DG F
donc il faut voir si c'est le
cas faut voir si c'est le cas ou c'est
pas le cas si là on a eu des délais
exceptionnellement rapides pour des
pressions donc ça c'est le premier sujet
puis le deuxème sujet c'est qu'il faut
éclairer autre chose j'ai entendu
monsieurarmin qui disait oui on est
content que Monsieur Neymar Vienne en
France d'accord c'est comme ça qui
justifiait aussi l'amendement qui était
passé par le 493 sans vote à l'Assemblée
nationale qui heureusement éta déclaré
antionstitutionnelle qui permettait à la
FIFA de s'installer en France payer
d'impôt cotisation sociale zone franche
on nous dir bah oui c'est bien que la
FIFA vine bah non la FIFA ou Neymar
c'est bien si qu' payent leurs impôts et
ne serait-ce que par rapport à la
concurrence par rapport à d'autres
sports ou d'autres clubs donc ça c'est
pas possible de de d'adapter notre
fiscalité par rapport à des exceptions
du football ou moins qu'on plusur c'est
qu' a de l'argent quoi sur cette affaire
du PSG qu'on comprenne bien ça peut être
légal que le
gouvernementit accorde du net fiscale au
PSG pour il y a des accords des fois qui
existent dans certaines choses on le
sait donc il faut voir à quel niveau
c'est légal moi de ce que je lis dans la
presse ça l' est pas vraiment donc voilà
je vais mais je veux pas je veux pas
préjuger avant de regarder c'est pour ça
que j'ai demandé ces documents si je
vois qu'il y a des anormalité je pense
que ça sera je peux pas donner les
documents en tant que tel parce que là
j'ai pas le droit de transmettre
publiquement descumau mais ça sera je le
ferai savoir et par exemple on pourrait
très bien proposer que la commission des
finances s'autosaisisse en commission
d'enquête sur cette question Éric CoCr
la dernière question internationale sur
la guerre entre Israël et le Hamas vous
allez en février vous déplacer à Rafa
quel est l'objectif parlementair bah
pour demander la même chose que demande
la France le cesser le feu essayer de le
promouvoir faut que ça s'arrête euh
voilà il faut que ça s'arrête 24000
morts palestiniens euh 70 % de femmes et
enfants parmi ces 24000 morts ça peut
pas continuer comme ça on peut pas
continuer à rayer un peuple de de de la
terre en terme d'entité territoriale les
je vous rappelle que leenu parle de
risque génocidaire donc faut ça s'arrête
et pour ça bah il faut essayer de de de
de faire du bruit enfin du bruit je veux
dire bien sûr Pacifique donc on ira à
Rafa avec effectivement une vingtaine de
parlementaires et qui allez qui
allez-vous rencontrer déjà on va aller à
la frontière parler de ça essayer de le
faire savoir puis très certainement on
va essayer de rencontrer des
associations humanitaires qui
travaillent là-bas des autorités on va s
rencontrer les autorités égyptiennes qui
nous autorisent à traverser le Sinaï
voilà c'est un voyage pour pousser pour
qu'il a des règlements diplomatique de
cette question et que les Palestiniens
que à la fois Israël a le droit à la
sécurité mais que les palestinens CIT un
état et qu'on arrête de massacrer les
Palestiniens et de faire ce qui est en
train d'être fait c'estd non pas rayer
le Hamas de la carte mais Brayer la
Palestine de la carte et pourquoi vous
ne rencontrez pas aussi les autorités
israéliennes qui ont un rôle à jouer
dans ce conf j'ai cru comprendre qu'il y
a plein de gens qui les rencontrent il y
a pas de problème depuis quelques temps
là j'entendais qu'il y a des voyages qui
ont lieu là la la la plupart du la not
notre problème à nous là du côté ça va
de voir ceux qui en ce moment sont en
train d'être bombardés qu'on expulse
progressivement de leur territoire euh
ce qui est d'ailleurs à mon avis un des
objectifs de guerre de monsieur
netanahou qui était annoncé avant C on
finir avec toute possibilité d'un État
palestinien voilà on va on va je je
pense qu'on va aller voir ceux qui en ce
moment subissent quelque chose qui n'est
pas qui n'est pas qualifiable et parmi
les parlementaires qui vous
accompagneront les différentes familles
politiques sont représentées euh oui oui
c'est ma volonté pour l'instant il y a
surtout des formations de gauche mais là
je suis en train de ça vient juste de se
refinaliser pour tout vous dire on on
attendait les accords égyptiens on a
évidemment les accords du côté du
ministère des Affaires étrangères et
c'est ouvert à à je fais un appel c'est
ouvert à toutes personnes qui le
souhaiteraiit du côté des des groupes
démocratiques merci beaucoup Éric cocrel
d'avoir été notre invité politique ce
matin tout de suite le club des
territoires